o frio mas que é a primeira vez na
história deste canal eu faço um vídeo tá
dizer que não tem vídeo tá gelado aqui
em columbus ohio e eu tô fazendo isso
aqui com vocês tô lembrando o vídeo tô
dizendo tirar a blusa se não é os
comentários vídeo é só isso antes de
búzios não é o sequestraram aí eu já vai
clicando em gostei aí tá bom quanto eu
passo meu protetor ambiente não rachou
beijo irônico demais isso é lá no piauí
só racho chão a não raça me fala uma
maior assim agarrado aqui rebateu ouvir
o coringa tem que andar com esta merda
toda hora passando na boca parece todo
tempo que eu comi um
e até ficar igual da menina que vão para
a escola [ __ ] merda o tamanho do negócio
meu deus dá para amarrar seis cabelo
afrouxou meu deus quantas vou dar jesus
aí a última não passa todos os cabelos
que precisa passar por e aí galera que
assiste meu canal tudo bom com vocês
pagando fica vídeo eu estou aqui para
explicar por que que nunca tem vídeo é o
seguinte deixa eu situar a vida do
whindersson nunes para você eu escrevo
para cá eu tenho ficado bem famoso não é
verdade tudo que acontece na minha
carreira assim na minha vida quando você
ver um show do netflix quando você ver
um filme no cinema quando parece que é
uma coisa assim meu aleatória que
acontece ou esporádica mas não é é um
trabalho muito bem pensado e muito bem
feito para poder acontecer e chegar para
você whindersson de uma outra forma né
como por exemplo netflix por cento na
netflix me digita o meu nome tem um show
meu lado então não se tiver criança
assistindo não faz isso tem que dizer né
porque senão ser aí você não pode falar
um pouco para um [ __ ] a criançada vai
lá na cozinha aberta aparada
e quem foi que disse a um ponto
whindersson nunes que ensinou tá com
tablet na casa da criança joga uma faca
ali no chão para ir brincar com a faca
também perto do a tomada foi isso nunes
que ele falou é você tiver criança não
repete isso tá criança faz quando tem um
produto assim é todo um trabalho por
exemplo eu tenho que ir lá bora qualquer
pessoa com uma parte em baixo e por
favor é porque eu acredito muito meu
potencial e tem que convencer tem que
fazer bem feito e tem que ter tudo tudo
isso aí é uma da unidade de medida mais
importante que tem agora na minha vida
que é o tempo a então isso quer dizer
que o youtube não está no meio desse
tempo aí então aqui é uma merda você não
é que durante um tempinho você se dedica
mais alguma outra coisa só para poder
fazer aquele negócio ali você quer
fazendo ir depois você se dedica o outro
tempo a outra coisa entendeu e nesse
momento agora hoje que horas são relógio
[ __ ] que pariu minha vó apertar você não
sabe falava hora são 4:46 da manhã quer
dizer nem porta nem a hora que que eu tô
falando importa hora posso falar
qualquer hora que for bloqueado
e são 29 horas agora aqui em columbus
ohio é assim a hora que festejou hoje em
columbus ohio muito obrigado todos os
brasileiros que foram assistir tem
aqueles formas né fabuloso hoje no caso
um dia que esse vídeo tá sendo postado
eu acho que deve estar acontecendo nesse
momento o show de chicago aí 7 de março
agora que vem agora sábado tem newark
nova jersey dia oito tá então todo em
filadélfia 13m de farmácia chopp 14
fotos wood 16 washington 18 nova orleans
19 urbanil 20 orlando 21 a planta 22
tampa para encerrar fechar com a tampa
tudo isso porque que eu estou em turnê
pelos estados unidos para que o início
aqui ontem um brasileiro eu tô eu vou
informando e reconheço vai todo lugar
que eu chego as pessoas diz meu deus
cara que massa que você vem ninguém vem
aqui resolveu pingar que o chuveiro e
cai em cima da torneira de ferro atender
da banheira
e no tempo meu pai é um modo que eu
tenho dez me divertindo essa minha vida
muito louca e vai a muito dinheiro
quando eu vou gastar o dinheiro por bora
bora o aparelho entra dentro do carro
mesmo tempo que estão mais atrasado vai
atrasar para que o almoço aqui para o
almoço não dá tempo sair na hora certa e
é o moço como é que eu vou atrasar o
almoço eu vou que eu vou fazer o almoço
mas eu acho que é essa cara minha missão
onde estarás um brasileiro estará seu
também e a justamente por essa falta de
tempo que talvez no próximo ano a gente
não tenha mais shows rodando aí pelo
mundo pelo brasil também porque
realmente por conta disso tem condição
não dá meu amigo eu tô gravando dentro
do banheiro que eu comecei a gravar ali
fora batendo na porta do quarto que eu
tava falando alto e aqui estados unidos
assim meu amigo gente passou do limite
agora tadeu época eu tô aqui gravando
dentro do banheiro e não tem eco que eu
não entendi isso também parabéns estados
unidos eu não fui pagar pau não mas o
banheiro você fala e não sai não faz
diferença bacana que também é o único
lugar que fica legal
é uma luz bacana posso botar aqui casa
de maquiagem não sei botaram dois legal
aqui e aí tem dois papelzinho de
decoração de um bichinho eu usei de um e
de outro para ficar né tornando aí
começou a ficar fim de mais um gol aí tô
fazendo tudo nem para nos estados unidos
já deste vírus aí tá botando no meio do
mundo todinho eu tô me banhando de
álcool gel é uma situação que não é para
ter pânico mas você não tem como ter
pânico né pagar um pânico que se instala
em um banco que ele vem do nada de um
pouquinho que tá tudo bem tá tranquilo
não não não já já já tá contendo já está
revertendo vai morreu dois ele tem esse
um bebê aí quem tóxico é twitter pão
foram na vida você quer gente o meu deu
nele né ninguém vai trabalha aquela
coisa engrenagem é daqui a pouco bbb
daniel perde 100 mil instalex porque
existiu sei lá também tem não tem que
fazer piada e vender mais que toda
semana vocês escolhe um para gostar e
depois desgosto agora daquela e gosta de
novo agora eu tô gostando tô gostando
agora ali ó eu amava-a até agora toda a
e depois já gosta daqui de novo não
gosta aqui aquela coisa eu não sei que é
burro morreu um ali ó até um coronavírus
battle panic tumba de novo e fica meu
deus do céu aí vai para o twitter e léia
aí fica meu deus do céu jesus amado não
acredito que o daniel esqueceu o
microfone de novo fica.com daniel
esqueceu o microfone de novo mas eu não
estressa número é dele é uma que eu não
assisto aí eu tô fazendo turnê nos
estados unidos meu amigo eu não pegar o
celular eu dou tchau pessoa de longe a
pessoa vira as costas o que gelzinho na
mão é todo tempo é que tá beleza bacana
a chegar no brasil deve o meu dedo por
dentro chupar e bebendo é da hora que eu
acordo a hora que eu vou dormir eu vou
ver com vocês tudo isso que eu falei no
vídeo não é o motivo de não ter sido
motivo de não ter vídeo é porque eu sou
perfeccionista apesar de ser assim
jogado que chega e dá o play gravando
vamos fazer um vídeo aqui eu gosto isso
aqui todo artesanal zinho sabe eu gosto
de ter um assunto que tem futuro vai até
o fim tem um negócio bacana só que os
títulos do vídeo não faço o cliente
baixos e clicar e chega lá e não é minha
mãe escorregou levou à queda bateu a
cabeça aí a foto da manhazinha jonathan
e você clica e não é os meus e clique é
bronco rico e pobre também tem clica no
vídeo chega lá tá o assunto que ele e
todo mundo faz que eu não faço eu vou
botar o dedo esse vídeo vou botar peguei
coronavírus nos estados unidos eles
fazer uma pergunta né eu voltar até a
mechinha para cada verde ela botar o
dito assim que todo dia também inventa
notícia falsa com meu nome eu mesmo que
é dito quando sou eu que digito eu mando
um amigo meu que é dita igual a mim aí
ele manda para mim eu ainda corrijo
mando para ele
e aí jair manda para mim aí manda ele
assim vai vai vai até ficar do jeito que
eu dou play eu assisti e faz assim é
legal bacana para quem tá comigo legal
né eu posso me sinto muito bem assim
qualquer coisa que você não tá
aparecendo não fui eu fiz que a espera
vai ser classificada que tá vendo aí uma
paródia do largados e pelados aquele
programa de descobrir que eles algumas
pessoas no lugar e deixá-la com fome
sede e vão embora só busca no site vocês
gostem clica em gostei assim que você
explicaram nesse tá se não clicou
lembrando que agora você brasileiro
angolano moçambicano cabo-verdiano chama
e seu amigo brasileiro avise o seu amigo
brasileiro que mora em algum da cidade
que eu falei nos estados unidos vamos
para o show compra ingressinho manda uma
mensagem para essa amiga aí vamos mesmo
e nós vem para onde aí tudo show doente
sabia não sabia não o meu irmão só tem
dois ingressos o meu e o teu brother
muito legal é muito engraçado né
o clima lá é muito bacana uma energia
assim que se você tá precisando dar uma
animada vai no que tá muito legal é
muito divertido e o dólar tá muito alto
seu ingresso é uma brastemp mas
brincadeiras à parte acham que eu gosto
muito esse é o show que eu mais gosto de
fazer tais também vai para o netflix tá
não é o mesmo que tá lá até porque não
tem como botar dois o mesmo como você
sabe o show é uma coisa que fala sobre a
minha vida então deixou consequentemente
eu tô falando sobre depressão viagem
força safári na áfrica interior do piauí
é tanta coisa que você quiser ir tá
feito o convite tamo junto obrigado por
ter assistido o vídeo até aqui desculpa
a demora quer falar demais e muita coisa
muita besteira e muito enrola para dizer
que não tem vídeo porque eu sou um
perfeccionista com essas coisinhas que
eu gosto de fazer estamos junto um
beijão fica com deus vou terminar essa
turnê dos estados unidos inteira volta
para o brasil grava o filme toma filha
da [ __ ] obrigado tamo junto um beijo
carinhoso noite vai